sometimes even the most powerful
filmmakers in hollywood
take the long way to getting their
visions on screen
from the involvement of a legendary
filmmaker to the future of the franchise
here's the untold truth of elita battle
angel
though elita battle angel premiered in
theaters in february 2019
james cameron had been developing the
project for quite a while
in fact cameron was pursuing elita all
the way at the dawn of the 21st century
back in june 2000 news sprung up that
20th century fox
had registered a website domain related
to elita for cameron
at the time fox had no comment on what
specific plans they had for this webpage
coming less than three years after
cameron's titanic had dominated the
planet
though grabbing that sight couldn't help
but draw eyeballs
it seemed to be news that positioned
elita as the next directorial effort
from the king of the world
as history is proven though all that
speculation
around 2000 never led to much though he
went back and forth on which project to
do
as his next directorial effort cameron
eventually shifted his sights onto
avatar
his connection to elita would be further
distanced once the director's chair was
filled by robert rodriguez
still cameron remained an integral
creative partner on the project
the fact that he was pursuing this
endeavor all the way back in 2000
speaks to his enduring passion for the
world of elita
as the 21st century began cameron always
wanted to push the envelope for visual
effects
was looking to make movies starring
entirely digital characters
both elita and avatar were being
eyeballed by the attur
as ways of realizing those ambitions
with the former
initially being the one cameron planned
to make into a groundbreaking reality
first
all the way back in 2004 cameron was
teasing the movie
which he dubbed battle angel as a
project featuring a main character done
entirely in cg
animation which would be shot with a new
3d imaging system he'd developed for
documentaries
cameron's visual effects ambitions for
the project were clear from the get-go
while his explicit mention of battle
angel being in pre-production
made it obvious he planned to get to the
film next
however plans eventually changed cameron
debated whether he'd direct avatar or
battle angel next
but camera tests eventually led him to
pursue the former instead in the process
alita went from being a top priority to
getting shifted to cameron's back burner
it can take a while for a movie's visual
effects work to come together just right
that's why a number of blockbusters
begin working on their most vfx heavy
sequences before principal photography
even begins in the case of elita battle
angel it shouldn't be shocking to
discover that the cutting edge
technology
used to bring those robotic characters
to life was being worked on
long before cameras started rolling
however what is surprising
is just how long this vfx technology was
being fine-tuned
elita battle angels vfx were being
worked on for more than a decade
before it ever hit the silver screen
according to a may
2006 profile from variety james cameron
had spent about 10 months at that point
working on the visual effects technology
necessary to bring the movie to life
cameron even at these earliest stages
planned to render elita the character as
an entirely digital creation
so he wanted to make sure the technology
used for this protagonist was just right
of course cameron's early prep work
didn't pan out as he focused his
attention
on jake sully and his adventures on
pandora
still having elita's vfx date all the
way back to 2005
reflects cameron's determination to
render this anime character right
in live action robert rodriguez doesn't
frequently play in the sandbox of big
budget movies
he certainly made vfx heavy features but
budgets on the scale of a james cameron
mega blockbuster
aren't exactly rodriguez's wheelhouse
though he embraced
this style of filmmaking when he took on
elita battle angel
rodriguez's original participation in
the production was meant to be quite a
bit more limited
initially rodriguez was simply called in
to help revise the film's screenplay but
he grew more invested when he saw the
design work
at play as he explained to the irish
times i saw james cameron's original
drawings
and they took my breath away and he
trusted me with the version
that was in his head and he said if you
fix the script for me
you can direct so a month later i come
back and say
here you go free of charge and he said
all right
it's yours after that rodriguez went
from being a screenwriter on elita
battle angel to being its sole director
i said if you can crack the code and you
want to do it
let's do it elita actress rosa salazar
became one of the most acclaimed parts
of elita battle angel
with critics praising how she was able
to convey a richly human
performance through all that motion
capture animation technology
however despite how widely beloved
salazar's elita has become
she wasn't always the only person in
contention for the role
originally the title role of velita
battle angel came down to a number of
actresses
including future spider-man mainstay
zendaya the hollywood reporter noted in
april 2016
that zendaya salazar and it follows lead
micah monroe
were all finalists for the role of elita
bella thorne was also mentioned as a
name and consideration for the part
interestingly at the time thr said that
zendaya was the front-runner for the
role
but cautioned that the performer's
commitments to her disney channel
program
kc undercover could provide
insurmountable scheduling conflicts
it turned out those conflicts were
impossible to resolve
and zendaya failed to secure the role of
elita while other contenders like monroe
and thorne
also fell by the wayside instead salazar
took on the part forever altering her
career in the process
i do not stand by in the presence of
evil
robert rodriguez needed to make a number
of changes to his filmmaking style when
tackling elita battle angel
the man famous for handling all behind
the scenes elements of his independent
productions had to hand over the reins
of cinematography
music and editing to other people
meanwhile the sheer scope of the entire
endeavor
meant he had to pull back on some of his
most outlandish tendencies
one thing that didn't change though was
that elita was shot
in rodriguez's go-to filming location of
austin texas
the home of rodriguez's troublemaker
studios elita shot on soundstages in the
city
with apparently the entire feature being
filmed there this makes it a rare
big-budget production to shoot in texas
many blockbusters opt to shoot elsewhere
thanks to tax incentives
however those concerns weren't going to
show away rodriguez
in fact he's got a sense of loyalty
fueling his ambitions
to shoot his film in this famous texas
city
as he told the irish times richard
linklater and i both live there and i
have to say
by staying in your community and making
your movies there
and using local workers it creates a
ripple effect that is ultimately
huge with that kind of potential
positive impact it's no wonder
that elita battle angel and its backdrop
of iron city found a home
in the lone star state elita battle
angel
did okay but not necessarily fantastic
at the worldwide box office thanks to a
lack of new american blockbusters in the
first two months of 2019
it managed to do significantly better
domestically than many other live-action
anime adaptations but it still grossed
just over 85 million dollars
domestically
thanks to overseas grosses including a
strong gross in china
alita brought its worldwide box office
hall to 401.9 million dollars
that isn't spectacular on a budget
that's been speculated to range from 170
million dollars to a whopping 200
million dollar range
however it's a decent gross on a number
of levels particularly when you compare
its domestic haul
to its international one while it might
not have done james cameron blockbuster
numbers
elena was also notable because it became
robert rodriguez's biggest movie ever
at the worldwide box office the film
easily leaped past rodriguez's previous
biggest movie ever
the first spy kids film with almost
double the box office total
of course this isn't exactly a shocking
development giving that rodriguez hadn't
previously dabbled in the kinds of
movies that make
over 400 million dollars worldwide when
many of your features are low budget
grind house homages
like machete of course a broadly
appealing tentpole like elita
will become your highest grossing
directorial effort however
it's still a noteworthy achievement for
elita battle angel
especially considering that its box
office run as a whole
didn't quite meet expectations
throughout elita battle angel a handful
of big name actors
show up for brief appearances jai
courtney
pops up as legendary motorball player
joshu gunn
and edward norton appears as the film's
ultimate villain
nova in the moment they're just further
evidence of the larger world that elita
occupies
in the broader context though these
characters and their respective
performers were all supposed to pay off
in potential follow-ups to elita battle
angel as rodriguez
explained in an interview with coming
soon we had to cast these people without
really having a part for them to be
basing it on
to see if they wanted to do it there was
no script for a future one
so we went to people we knew according
to rodriguez these elita cameos were the
last casting they did on the film
in part because the roles were so small
there wasn't a lot of preparation
necessary
delaying the casting also meant
rodriguez and company could really feel
out
who was right for the roles just in case
they didn't get the chance to come back
for sequels
while the future of elita battle angel
as an ongoing cinematic universe is
uncertain
if any sequels do emerge the first movie
has ensured that a handful of big actors
are ready to fill out critical
characters
nobody involved with elita battle angel
could have ever predicted the film would
occupy a notable place in film history
however that's just what happened when
the film was released in the middle
of february 2019 it may have been just a
spot on the calendar at one point but at
the time this meant the film was the
last title released by 20th century fox
before the studio was absorbed into
disney
in march 2019 that's right nearly 85
years of 20th century fox existing
as a non-disney entity came to a close
with leda
though there could never be a perfect
closing film for a studio that
encompassed
so many eras of history concluding on
alita meant that fox went out with a
feature
hailing from one of its biggest go-to
filmmakers
james cameron after all the man behind
fox's two biggest movies at the
worldwide box office
avatar and titanic was also the producer
and screenwriter behind the studio's
final pre-disney release it also meant
that fox went out with a big budget
temple
rather than a smaller scale title that
could have slipped through the pop
culture cracks
initially elite battle angel was meant
to spawn further adventures
and director robert rodriguez noted that
his experience writing the film
meant that he had a clear perspective on
how the character could continue in
future installments
as he explained to yahoo movies whether
you have a franchise
or not you have a character that's so
rich that the audience can imagine more
movies with
those are the kinds of characters that i
like unfortunately
the film's worldwide box office was
nowhere near big enough to immediately
trigger
a green light for such projects despite
those issues though
rodriguez hasn't given up on seeing
further elite adventures
as recently as january 2021 the director
said
that a follow-up could emerge thanks to
the power of streaming services
as he told forbes i think anything is
possible disney bought fox
and they have disney plus so that is
worth the conversation
i know other people would love to see
another and i would love to do another
one
no further updates have emerged so it's
unclear if this is just wishful thinking
on the part of rodriguez
but with the avenue of streaming
services elita fans
may still have a whisper of hope of
seeing further adventures
in iron city check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]
you